well let's take you to some breaking
news that we're getting just in as I was
just saying we are getting reports of
drones and Rocket attacks on the anal
Assad Airbase that holds us and sorry
hosts Us and other International forces
in Western Iraq now according to the
Reuters news agency multiple blasts were
heard inside the base anal Assad is
located in the western anbar Province
well let's now speak to Mahmud Abdul
Wahid our correspondent who joins us now
on the phone from Baghdad obviously this
could be a huge development mahm what do
we know so
far well this is the second time Asad US
military base being targeted in uh two
days not only that another uh US
military base namely alh military base
in Northern Iraq uh was targeted also
yesterday on Wednesday and in all the uh
uh in all cases uh armed groups
affiliated to Iran claimed the
responsibility for the uh attacks we
have been noticing that such attacks
have been increasing uh uh following the
military campaign by Israel on Gaza trip
they have been speaking openly uh armed
groups affiliated to Iran in Iraq have
been speaking openly since the military
campaign on Gaza claiming responsibility
for the attack and not only that vowing
to uh launch more attacks on military
bases and American us interests in Iraq
in fact uh they have been pledging to uh
mobilize forces and people to go to Gaza
as they say to defend Gaza and to defend
Palestine against the Israeli uh
military uh
campaign ABD here there with the latest
for us on that from Baghdad we'll be
staying across all developments for you
here on Al jaaz